- On this episode,
we go Facebook live.
Hard.
(upbeat hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- We're good?
We're super live.
- [Staphon] Super live.
- Not just live--
- [Staphon] No, super live.
- I don't even remember.
- [India] Hey everybody
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk--
- Yeah. Thank you.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 208
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
And this is a very, very,
very special episode of
The #AskGaryVee Show as
we continue to experiment.
You know what?
We had the Golden Era and I
think these last 25, 30 shows
maybe 15 shows have been
like the experimental era.
Right?
We've tried a lot
of different things.
We're trying to find our cadence
to the next thing and this is a
Facebook Live episode so
what were doing on this episode
instead of the call-in
we're using the Facebook live
technology there's all
sorts of things on here.
Staphon's got a wire.
Brit's actually live on it
right now, I just heard myself.
I'm weirded out.
I have to collect my composure.
But to get on this show right
now everybody watching live on
Facebook Live you can actually
ask your question in the
comments right to India.
India asks boom the whole
thing works, it's very 2016.
I'm very excited about it.
And also let's make sure
that we Share Bear it up.
Everybody share right now if
you're watching share this up.
I would love to get some new
audiences into the funnel of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
If you care about your friends
and family and acquaintances and
ex-boyfriend's whatsoever
please share it up.
India, you feeling ready
to have some questions?
All ready?
- I'm ready.
I have two but I want
people to start asking me more.
- [Gary] We should
really do this.
Let's do let's get
into the Facebook show.
- Let's get into
the Facebook show?
- Yeah. Ready?
- Okay. Yeah.
- Let's--
- Get into--
- the Facebook--
- [Both] Show.
- By the way,
a really funny thing
a really funny thing is
how many people in Amsterdam
asked me to do the show thing.
- [India] Oh really?
- It's become a whole
meme when I travel.
Selfies and like hey would you
mind just doing the show with me
and then I have to do with them.
- [India] That's cool.
- You've become a
global icon, India.
- [India] Wow. I love that.
Are you ready?
- Always.
- [India] First one from Tony.
- Tony.
- [India] What is the most
important lesson you
learned from Mike?
- What is the most important
that I've learned from Mike?
That I very much appreciate
people who are consistent and
are willing to grind in the
way that I like to roll and it's
very important to me to level
up everybody that surrounds me.
Because every minute counts,
quality counts, for Mike not to
miss a single day including the
one time Mike actually got drunk
for the second time in his life
literally came in drunk, dead,
finished and just laid in
the gym while I worked out.
Like laid, like a baby.
Like a 20-year-old frat guy
crushed from the night before.
Like on the ground.
I think he got drunk at Nate
and Trouty's house, by the way,
which is the funniest part.
I appreciate,
that I am a fan of,
I'd love to say that I only
talk about what I believe in
that when I see it in somebody
else it's extremely valuable and
reinforces the tried and true.
Two years the guy
never missed a single day.
Came through every time.
Didn't miss a single flight.
And really did a tremendous job.
That consistency does matter and
I know I do it but feeling it on
the other hand was
very, very rewarding.
And I'm going to miss Mike a
lot over the next several weeks
he'll be around with Jordan
transition stuff but it is quite
emotional for me.
- [India] It is emotional.
- Yeah.
- [India] From Jordan--
- Not the new Jordan.
- [India] Not the new Jordan.
- Jordan is the name
of the new trainer.
He's in for three years.
We won't feel the transition
quite as quickly.
- [India] How would you scale
a wedding photography business
with basically no
recurring dollars?
- Meaning like he just
doesn't have a lot of money?
- [India] Yeah. Yeah, I guess.
- He doesn't have
business model that's recurring.
It's I get a wedding,
I shoot it, I get money.
So how would you scale?
First and foremost, if I'm a
wedding photographer, one of the
first moves I would do is
very similar to the advice that
I gave to designers, immediately
I would layer a tier of
Snapchat filter capabilities.
I believe every modern wedding
35 and under in America
in the next 18 months is
gonna have a Snapchat filter.
It's going to be a big
thing like Karen and Rick.
That thing.
I would do modern marketing.
One, I would go triple in,
quadruple in, all-in uploading
all your photos five, seven a
day get approval do your thing
on Instagram and
learn all 15 hashtags
that matter on Instagram.
The five most popular ones,
the five medium ones and
five long tail ones
like #HamptonsWedding.
You know, #RockawayWeddings.
Your area that you shoot in.
There is always that hall,
that place that everybody gets
married at using
that name and weddings.
15 hashtags against 5 to 7
photos every single day on
Instagram, I think will
lead to tremendous business.
The other thing that I would do
is I would try to guest blog on
wedding sites about Instagram
and Snapchat because again
if you're watching my show you're
kind of aware of
these things, right?
Use modern social creative as
your linchpin to your
actual business.
If you think about being a
photographer for weddings as a
secondary thing and you think
about being great in Snapchat
and Instagram around the wedding
industry, using it and then
commentating on it you will
create a much bigger awareness
funnel and then people are like,
"Oh, I want to use that girl,
"that guy. They're good and
Snapchat and Instagram and
"wedding photos.
It's 2016, 2017."
I would hustle.
I would work.
What I just said took work.
You like that one, Andy?
It's real.
Work three more, four more hours
a day to do it I just told you
and amazing things happened.
You know how many people are
like "Oh miraculously, I made
"$500 this week on eBay because
instead of drinking beers on my
"porch and watching
Thunder-Warriors I went in my
"garage or when garage
sale-ing and I sold stuff."
Staphon smiled because he
watched all of Thunder-Warriors.
- [Staphon] I sure did.
(laughter)
- That's why has $500
less in his pocket.
But he has the memories
and enjoyed himself.
- [Staphon] It was a great game.
- Escapism.
Great games.
- [India] From Ash.
- Ash.
- [India] What is the best
advice you give to someone that
wants to start a small business
but they're still
working full time?
- To do it after your hours.
It was called Crush It!
I wrote it in '08 it came out in
'09, 7PM to two in the morning.
This is all the same things.
Are you guys willing to
put in the work and pay...
Guys, are you willing to pay
the price for what you want?
I want to have a business so I
can make lots of money and go on
vacation and have lots of things.
You want a 1% life but you're
not willing to put
in a 1% worth ethic.
Work your job, come home
and do I have to go
through it again?
Do I have to make fun of
"Game of Thrones" and
the Golden State Warriors
one more time.
I'm more than happy too.
You've got to give up all the
leisure stuff and you got to
work from seven to
two in the morning.
Start a business,
sell shit on eBay.
I put that out there.
Everybody can do that.
Become the wedding
photographer of America like
I became the wine guy.
Not everybody can do that.
You've got to make the mental
switch in the same way that two
years ago I said I'm going to
make, there was no tactic to get
into better shape.
Get in here.
Get it here.
- What's up?
- Timing is unbelievable.
- Good.
I was just talking about my
health switch ironically you
started around the time that I
was starting to smoke around it.
- Yes. That's right.
- You're an unbelievably
athletic kinda dude.
- Sure.
- You agree with me that it is
a mental switch not a tactic.
- Oh yeah.
- There's no do this.
It's binary either
you're mentally
in the place I take it
seriously or you're not.
- Life does
whatever it's gonna do.
You just gonna decide what
you're going to do around it.
And that happens with
exercise too I think.
So yeah just go
with it or you don't.
- One or zero.
- Thank you.
(laughter)
Ah, that hurt.
Do you remember two years
ago when we went to
Vayner Camp and he climbed
the wall in one second?
Do you know about this?
- [India] Yeah.
- Like this wall thing that
everybody was like, yeah.
It took him one second.
He's a machine.
Anyway.
What's the person's, Ash?
- [India] Ash.
- Ash, what's my recommendation?
Unless you've been in my cycle
for the last 30 or 60 days and
I'm new to you I'm going to
get really pissed off at you.
The work.
And by the way, you may not be
good enough to make $10 million
a year with the work
that you make $4,000 but
it still gonna be the work.
I can't instill more talent into
you you can do a very good job
trying to find white spaces and
figure out what you are good at.
But once you put in the work.
The talent the white
spaces that's a coin flip.
That's a lot of DNA,
that's a lot of luck,
that's a lot of skill.
There's a lot of things there
but the work is always
part of the equation.
And that's the part
none of you want to do.
Can we just finally have
this conversation together?
You just don't want to do it.
You just don't.
You really don't.
You say you do but you don't.
You'd rather lay in bed
and sleep in for 15 hours.
You'd rather play video games.
You'd rather play
bullshit games on your phone.
You'd rather watch TV
you'd rather watch this show.
You'd rather go play beer pong.
You'd rather do
something else than work.
It's hard.
Which is why I push people to
do work around their passions
because it makes a
little bit easier.
If I had to do this
around bricklaying, I'd suck.
- [India] Good?
- Great.
- [India] Okay.
- And you know, no
I'm just kidding.
(laughter)
- [India] I knew it.
I knew it.
From Rob.
- [Gary] Rob.
- You're huge sports fan.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Which athlete do you relate to
the most or compare yourself to
as you're in the blank
of digital marketing?
- I don't really think that
way but I will say that you know
watching the Kobe documentary on
Showtime definitely I was like
boy can I really
relate with, I am so scary.
It's unbelievable.
I wonder what DailyVee episode
is gonna really going to show
how competitive I really am.
I'm not competitive
with this audience.
I love this audience.
I'm trying to give
you guys advice.
I don't even want you
to watch me anymore.
Think about that.
I love this audience.
I'm not competitive with people
that have anointed me and gifted
me with their time and their
effort and their attention.
I have love for them.
You should see the
polar opposite of my love.
Because it's dark.
It's unbelievable how much
I hate my competition
with like visceral hate.
But then in real life I don't.
I want to kill them in business.
I want them to
go out of business
but then I want to help them
get back on their feet
but don't fucking
compete with me.
- [India] That was scary.
- No, it wasn't.
I'm telling you right
now, that's not even.
Do you know how weird I am?
Do you know that me
and AJ get into fights?
- [India] Corn hole
that was pretty insane.
- We talked about
this once or twice.
Do you know Agnes?
Where is she?
- [Andy] She's right there.
- Agnes!
- [Staphon] AK, I need yours,
cause your's doesn't lag.
Yeah.
- I need you.
(laughter)
Just for a second.
- Hi.
- Hey Agnes.
So I'm doing this
#AskGaryVee Show.
- Mhmmm.
- Right?
And I needed you because I'm
talking about this dark place
I go into when I compete.
- Oh.
(laughter)
We've all seen that.
- Right and so, there's that
one moment I don't know if you
remember but I do where
you had a breakaway and
I came from behind and I--
- You just shoved me to
the floor like no mercy.
- Yes.
- I absolutely remember that.
(laughter)
- I just thought it would be
more powerful to hear from you.
That was probably
inappropriate, right?
- No, that's fair competition.
Happens all the time.
- Yeah. Winner.
That's a winner mentality.
Thanks Anges.
- This is from yesterday.
- 'Cause you're a warrior.
Legit jump shoot too.
Awesome, thanks.
(laughter)
I think we can all agree that
Agnes is a nice 6-foot-5
brooding man.
- [India] Right.
- She was on a breakaway,
there was nothing.
Were you there that day Staphon?
- [Staphon] It was a while ago?
- Yeah.
- [Staphon] Yeah.
- When I just like--
- [Staphon] Yeah. Yeah.
- Inappropriately, 1989,
'92 NBA Knicks-Pistons,
Agnes the girl.
- [Staphon] Yeah.
- Yeah, that was inappropriate
but when it's competition I do
not care, by the way it actually
it works for me as a positive
for VaynerMedia.
I always laugh about minority,
female, things of that nature,
this is competition.
Whoever I think, I don't
care what even Patriot fans are
allowed at Vayner, right?
I'm very dark when it
comes to competition.
The Kobe stuff and I hate
Michael Jordan with my heart and
soul but even his speech where
he's just like it's all
about competition.
It's the game.
I love the game.
I don't like anybody
who wants to beat me.
And I really want to
beat their face in.
With a brick.
And I mean it.
Andy you agree.
In basketball, I'm mad.
Right?
When we play I'm mad
and that's basketball,
you haven't seen me
play Scattergories.
(laughter)
- [Brit] You were angry when
I met you playing trivia.
- Right!
- [Brit] The Christmas party.
- That was the first
time we met, right?
- [Brit] Yeah.
- And that was like, I was weird.
Competitive.
- [Brit] You were like
super competitive.
- Right. I was very upset.
- [Brit] Yeah, even if
you weren't necessarily
contributing, you
were very upset.
- [Gary] That's right.
If I didn't have any answer to
these questions I was mad at
them for not knowing.
- [Brit] It's true.
That's like, you know.
You should know something too.
I do plenty of
things around here.
We have this trivia
party because of me.
Why don't you get
the answer right to
this bullshit movie?
I don't watch movies.
You fuckers waste
time and watch movies.
I don't don't know movies.
I don't watch them.
- [Staphon] Getting fired up.
- Let's move on.
- [India] A very tactical one.
- [Gary] Yes, I don't care.
- [India] Carsten.
- [Gary] Carsten.
- Carsten, how would you
advertise a little house in
southern Spain near the ocean.
I rent it, I have a website, I
advertise in agency and I do
AirBnB but I still
need more customers.
Thanks and greets.
- Snapchat.
Instagram.
Facebook.
This is so...
Instagram hashtag strategy
is unbelievable.
Why don't you give away the
house to 50 influencers on
Instagram that have 1 million
followers, DM them and say
I have this
beautiful house here.
I would like you to come out.
Why don't you reach out to
Turkish Air or Delta or
Virgin America or something like
that and say I've got this house,
I want to surprise and delight
five influencers on Instagram
and have them come and stay
and then what you say is all you
have to do has have five photos
tag this, use this hashtag.
If you ask every airline in the
world 99.9% of them will say no
and one will say yes
because they just talked about
influencer marketing
the day before.
Now, you can go and Instagram
message somebody who's got
2 million fans and is a pretty
girl or boy and say you should
come and stay at my house
in this beautiful place.
I will have your
flight taken care of,
you can stay in my place,
in return I want 10 social
media pieces of content,
tag this.
Game over.
Winner. Over.
Then hashtag culture.
Figure out which hashtags
are being used and
put out way more content.
More content.
More content. More content.
Content is the cost of entry
for relevance in our society.
- [India] Nice.
- Thank you.
- [India] You haven't talked
much, oh, Kelsang,
crazy names today.
You haven't talked a bunch
about mobile first websites.
Advise for doing it well and
how do you structure
them for success?
- That's UI/UX talk.
That A/B testing.
That's first recognizing that
mobile first websites are the
cost of entry in 2016 if you are
not mobile first
you're gonna lose.
So when you design using
mobile then you think desktop.
Number two, you test your add to
cart button, you test your
sign up for my email service,
you test different colors,
different positionings,
A/B testing.
I don't talk about it because
there's a ton of people that are
far more knowledgeable about the
UI and UX of mobile optimization
for websites and I bet you they
have a tons of blogs and
videos out there.
There's a site called Google
and go search stuff and I'm sure
you'll find four to seven
personalities the way
I understand consumer behavior
and marketing in a social
digital mobile landscape.
I'm sure there's plenty of gals
and guys that know how to do it.
India what your picture in here?
- [India] Great. That's great.
Thanks.
- Can you get here Staphon?
How are you
feeling about your pic?
- [India] I mean it's fine.
- I like it.
- [Staphon] AK, let me see?
Let me see yours.
- [India] There we go.
- There we go.
Yeah.
(laughter)
That's a great shirt
you're wearing that day.
- Oh yeah, that's
the holiday party day.
When we played cornhole and
scared a lot of people,
going back to earlier themes.
- [Gary] Do you know what was
the recall you were there for
the camp at Lindsay's, did
you see me play volleyball?
- [India] No.
I heard about that though.
- Yeah, Lauren Brander
was scared.
(India's laughter)
Sorry Lauren.
- [India] From Sean.
- Sean.
- [India] What returns have you
seen with influencer marketing?
Is it just for massive brands
like Samsung or can a startup
turn revenue from
influencer marketing?
- A startup can turn
from influencer marketing.
Influencer marketing is reach
and is awareness and it works.
It's a boring question.
Everything that works, works for
everybody it just not possible
that you haven't figured out
your version of making it work.
Television. Super Bowl's
more expensive than
late-night remnant inventory,
but you can get it.
Everything, influencer
marketing works.
It's so underpriced.
- [India] All right.
- Search hashtags around
your business,
find people that
are influencers.
You know, if you're in a niche
business somebody who has 1000
followers may be the and biggest
influencer because you're not in
weight loss or in beer but
you're in SaaS business API
stuff but some nerd has 1000
people, the nerd probably cost
nothing and buy him or her out.
Buy him out Andy.
- [Andy] Buy him out.
- [India] Someone just say
Gary is Baw which I like.
(laughter)
- [India] Jake said
what are the best ways
to vanquish my enemies?
Which I also like.
- Actually, I have a
great answer this question.
- [India] Great.
- Because it's really what I do
which is ironic based on what we
just talked about with
competition back to me being
such an insane contradiction.
This is going to blow your mind.
By not giving them
the time of day.
It is insane how much I don't
understand about my competitors.
I don't even know their names.
That's how much
disrespect I have for them.
I'm being dead serious.
I never spent a minute.
I knew what the other
wine stores were doing.
I know the names of the other
agencies that are in our space.
I don't have a damn clue.
There hasn't been a minute on my
calendar in the last 36 months
that was based on getting
recon or intrigue on what any
competitor of mine is doing
because the very honest truth is
it doesn't matter what they're
doing because I'm going to get
mine and if they are good enough
they will get their's second.
Second rate.
But I'm gonna get mine.
So how do you vanish them
by establishing that they're
vanished from the get.
What do you want?
Just kidding, three minutes?
I'm in a very, I'm
in a Salty Vee mode.
I'm getting very competitive.
- [Andy] You want to ask a poll?
- You want a poll?
- [Andy] I want a poll.
- You want a poll to
throw it up there.
So I'm going to say something,
come up with a poll and
you're going to create it now?
- [Andy] Yeah.
It needs to be answers in the
comments need to be hashtaged
whatever the poll questions are.
- So they have to answer in
comments hashtag
whatever to my question?
- [Andy] Yeah, exactly.
- Okay.
Who do you like
more #India or #DRock?
(laughter)
- [India] The results
will show up live.
It's really cool.
- Amazing. Can't wait.
(laughter)
Rock it out.
- [Andy] In the comments
#India or #DRock.
- Yep.
In the comments #India or #DRock
and don't just because India's
here but DRock's not
don't pick India
if you like DRock more.
- [India] Yeah.
He's a nice guy, you know?
- [Gary] Or number
three #ShareBear.
- [India] Share
Bear's gonna win.
- [Staphon] Share Bear's
gonna take it.
- I think we need to
produce Share Bear plush toys.
- [India] That's
like a "Yay Andrew!"
His illustrations are so cool.
- [Staphon] Today's
his birthday.
- [India] Oh it's his birthday!
- Today is his birthday?
I thought yesterday
was his birthday.
Alright Andrew.
- [India] One more?
- One more.
Let's do it let's
wrap up the show.
I like this live.
Do they like it?
What are they
saying in the comments?
What is happening?
- [India] The people think lower
thirds are cool because the
questions are
popping up at the bottom.
- Right but what's the feedback?
- [Andy] DRock getting a lot.
- Well, DRock has GaryVee.
As DailyVee's become a
little bit more if we asked this
question four months ago
India woulda crushed him.
But now it's DRock.
- [India] It's gonna be rough.
- Soon it's going to be Staphon
because everybody gives DRock
love and then I jump in
and I'm like that's Staphon.
"Great edit, DRock."
Nope, Staphon.
- [India] I know.
- Are you, you're
editing right now 40, right?
- [Staphon] Yeah.
- How's it coming along?
- [Staphon] I haven't
started yet.
I just got the stuff.
- [India] How long until the
older generation gets Snapchat?
They said they'd never
get on Facebook and
we saw how that turned out.
Hahaha.
From Michael.
- Haha, Michael, soon.
Give me another one.
- [India] Another one?
- Trying to do a night
lightning round here.
India, you shoulda--
- [India] What's the number one
way of getting over the fear of
starting due to
potential haters?
And also what's your
tip on handling haters?
- Love you haters and number
two getting over the fear is
something you have to
wrap your head around.
It is just the cost of entry.
You will never do anything
great if you're scared.
- [India] I've worked in the
building supply industry for
10 years. In that time I made
any business can and I know many
small business
owners in my area.
- You want me to sign something?
- [India] I have $500, a computer,
internet, a car and a smartphone
what is the best way
to start a referral and
lead generating business?
- To get more 500 bucks.
Go to eBay and get
$5000 and then start.
Hustle.
If you have 500
bucks you need more.
You don't need more but
I'm very, very, very big on
understanding that lead referral
you're gonna have to run ads,
you're going to have a
create landing pages.
That's not what
you do with $500.
- [Man] Thanks.
- You build up $5,000 and I
think is $4500 worth of junk in
your basement and your garage
or you're auntie's garage
get that shit, flip it make
the cash, India.
- [India] One more?
- [Andy] Share Bear.
- Share Bear.
Oh, where is he?
Put him on my shoulder.
- [Andy] I'm trying.
- This is so funny.
Hold on.
Hello Share Bear.
- [India] Really cute.
- I love you Share Bear.
(laughter)
Share Bear is my friend.
You like that?
That's funny.
Guys, I love you.
Thank you so much for
supporting all of my content.
It's been amazing 60 days,
the shorts on Facebook,
two of them getting 20 million
organic reach, Andy.
Multiple million reach.
Thank you so much.
Keep sharing the content,
it means the world to me.
It's the greatest
gift that you give me.
Episode 208 success for
first time to do this.
I think we got something here.
We'll come back to this.
Thank you, India.
- [India] Yeah, no problem.
- Question of the day which you
can leave in these comments
too as this wraps up.
Question of the day,
the whole live experience
Periscope, Facebook Live.
What's your early takes on it?
What do you like?
What do you don't like?
Are you watching anything?
Give me your two sentence thesis
on the live revolution that is
happening right now on the web.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
What's up guys?
Hope you enjoyed the show.
Please do I get to
link it up anywhere?
Is it in here or
is it down below?
Is it in print or
is it in my video?
- [Staphon] It'll be down there.
It'll be down to your left.
- It's here down to my left.
Right here, there's a button
for them to subscribe
to my YouTube video?
Yeah it's that
little buggy thing.
That's right guys, click this.
That's right, use that.